what
is masochism without quite realizing it
many of us are masochists the word
derives
somewhat unfairly for him and his family
from the austrian 19th century
aristocrat and writer
leopold von sasha masak as a young man
leopold made a conventional marriage to
a fellow member of the nobility
aurora von but he swiftly discovered
that his sexual tastes could not be
accommodated within the relationship
when he was contacted by an admiring
reader
a baroness funny pistol under the
ostensible excuse of seeking help with
her writing style
he was able to discover a whole new side
to his sexual identity
what he wanted most of all was that
fanny would dress in a grand and
imperious looking fur coat
flog him dominate him and treat him with
haughty cruelty
he wanted fanny to call him gregor at
that time
a popular servant's name and when they
travelled
despite being far wealthier than her
insisted on being forced
to sit in third class while she took her
place
in first leopold's proclivities
which he wrote up in a lightly disguised
novella called venus infers
caught the interests of an austrian
psychiatrist
richard von kraft ebbing who despite
leopold's family's protestations
included them in his landmark compendium
of kinks
psychopathology of sex published in 1890
which introduced the world to the term
masochist
a person sexually aroused by being on
the receiving end
of pain we now understand a sexual
masochist
as somebody who might want to be called
obscenities
have their hair pulled or their skin
scratched or ordered to describe
themselves in highly derogatory and
humiliating terms
albeit it must be stressed with explicit
consent
for anything else would be merely
abusive
the mystery is why this could prove so
appealing and at points so
necessary to which psychotherapy has a
powerful answer
for the masochist cruel treatment in sex
play
is experienced first and foremost as a
relief
a relief from the inauthenticity and
alienating sentimentality
that can otherwise flow from being
treated with generous respect
masochists tend not to think too highly
of themselves
if others insist on handling them with
kid gloves
they cannot feel seen and understood it
only starts to seem properly real
and hence properly exciting when a
special partner spots the very
deep secret about them that they are
at least for a time and in a certain way
a stupid idiot
who deserves a severe beating
though the phenomenon of masochism began
with and has remained most fully
connected up to
sex it exists no less powerfully in the
emotional realm
there may indeed be many more emotional
masochists at large
than there are sexual ones as with
sexual masochism
emotional masochism is rooted in
self-suspicion
emotional masochists do not deep down
feel as if they are entirely lovable
people
worthy of careful appreciation and
kindness
if someone treats them well in love an
emotional masochist
would soon enough need to dismiss them
as needy and deluded
why after all would anyone feel better
about them
than they feel about themselves
in order to stop being an emotional
masochist
it is vital to start to imagine that one
might be one
to start to see perhaps for the first
time
the ways in which one is engaged in
self-sabotage
and has made an unconscious commitment
to loneliness and frustration
the task is also to see that the origins
of all this
lie as ever in early life
where the masochist is liable to have
relied on the affections of a parental
figure
who exhibited alongside their love a
high degree
of cruelty neglect or violence
leading the child to a conviction that
their destiny must lie
in suffering rather than fulfillment
the most relevant difference between
sexual and emotional masochism
is that the former activity will in the
right circumstances
be a lot of fun whereas the latter one
is never anything other than
slow bitter hell we owe it to ourselves
to start to see the myriad of ways in
which we may for far too long
have been holding ourselves back from
healthy relationships
not out of any kink or necessity just
because our
past has unfairly imbued us with a sense
that
unfeeling treatment is all we deserve
our pillow talk card set is designed to
spark the best kind of pillow talk
the sort where we explore sex with
intimacy
playfulness and intellectual curiosity
you